[Música]
queridos amigos amigas la pregunta que
muchos os estáis haciendo estos días es
hasta qué punto china va a apoyar a
rusia en la guerra de ucrania esta es
por así decirlo una de las piezas que
faltan en todo este puzzle china es la
mayor potencia rival de eeuu y
teóricamente se apoyará decididamente a
moscú el balance de fuerzas podría
cambiar radicalmente
[Música]
ahora bien esta es la teoría pero ocurre
lo mismo con la realidad hasta qué punto
estaría china dispuesta a involucrarse
pues para responder a estas preguntas lo
primero de todo es resolver otra
pregunta qué demonios piensa el gobierno
chino sobre la invasión de ucrania pues
una cosa y la otra que sí pero que no
porque amigos por un lado china antes de
la invasión llevaba ya tiempo diciendo
cosas como estas mensajes que luego ido
repitiendo una y otra vez si respalda la
oposición de putin a la expansión de la
otan en una cumbre que subraya lazos más
estrechos y además durante las primeras
horas de la invasión también dijeron
cosas como esta hemos declarado la
posición principal de china sobre la
cuestión de ucrania hay un trasfondo
histórico y un contexto complejo en este
asunto el ministerio de defensa ruso
dijo que sus fuerzas armadas no van a
llevar a cabo ataques con misiles aéreos
o de artillería en ciudades o hay un
gene directora adjunta del departamento
de información del ministerio de
relaciones exteriores de la república
popular china ya sabéis que es todo muy
complicado que no iban a atacar a
civiles en fin que es una operación
limitada para que la abuela fuma
etcétera etcétera y así siguieron
pasando los días hasta que invasión de
ucrania china se abstiene de votar en la
resolución del consejo de seguridad de
la onu para condenar a rusia y amigos ya
sabéis que hay silencios que resultan
atronador es la abstención de china tuvo
que ser toda una sorpresa para el
kremlin o tal vez no
fuera como fuese el caso es que los
chinos abandonaron a los rusos en la
votación y el kremlin contó sólo con el
apoyo de bielorrusia siria corea del
norte y eritrea menudo toda una puñalada
para la supuesta historia de márquez y
jean ping y vladimir putin han
protagonizado en los últimos años porque
amigos pocos líderes acumulan tantas
citas para que os hagáis una idea los
presidentes de rusia y de china se han
visto las caras y frotado las manos unas
40 veces incluso se dice que para no
aguar la fiesta a los chinos putin
esperó a que terminarán los juegos
olímpicos de pekín para lanzar su
invasión pero porque china entonces no
apoya a rusia en esta guerra sacará
acaso pekín provecho de toda esta
situación hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes veamos un
poco de historia
[Música]
destinados a entenderse
la unión soviética de lideró al bloque
comunista durante la guerra fría y en
sus primeros años contó con el apoyo del
país más poblado de la tierra la china
de mao tse tung juntos estaban llamados
a plantar cara al sistema capitalista de
occidente sin embargo amigos las
relaciones entre moscú y pekín se
torcieron después de la muerte de stalin
poco a poco las disputas entre chinos y
soviéticos fueron cada vez más sonadas
hasta que en 1969 llegaron a producirse
enfrentamientos armados entre las tropas
de ambos países a lo largo de la
frontera la frontera de más de 6000
kilómetros entre china y la unión
soviética estuvo fuertemente
militarizada durante décadas la extinta
urss mantuvo 44 divisiones desplegadas
hasta finales de los 80 13 divisiones
más que en el frente occidental contra
la otan
[Música]
pero tras la caída de la unión soviética
rusia china mejoraron bastante sus
relaciones e impulsaron una serie de
encuentros junto con otros países de
asia central eran conocidos como los
cinco de shanghai y su objetivo era
definir claramente las fronteras
políticas algo que resultaba fundamental
para reducir las tropas desplegadas con
el tiempo estos encuentros se
transformaron en toda una organización
internacional la organización de
cooperación de shanghai a la que emisor
político por cierto le dedicamos este
vídeo
actualmente la oce se ha ampliado sus
objetivos y forma parte de la estrategia
de china y rusia para construir
organizaciones internacionales al margen
de las instituciones que diseñó eeuu al
acabar la segunda guerra mundial de
hecho china y rúsia han intentado sacar
su propia alternativa al swift ahora por
cierto que la mayoría de los bancos
rusos no pueden usar el swift es muy
probable que se pasen al tips que es un
sistema creado por china
ojo no os equivoquéis el clips todavía
está a años luz del clásico swift ni
siquiera compiten en la misma liga el
swift es el sistema utilizado por más de
11.000 instituciones financieras de más
de 200 países diferentes mientras que
apenas 1200 instituciones en solo 100
países utilizan el sistema chino además
hay muchas dudas de que este sistema
puede usarse realmente en rusia sin
problemas porque pues atentos el sistema
de pago transfronterizo en yuanes
todavía depende de los bancos como nodos
que pueden ser sancionados e
influenciados eeuu puede sancionar a
estos bancos en swing profesor del
instituto avanzado de finanzas de
shanghai 2014 fue un punto de inflexión
cuando el kremlin seleccionó crime a
occidente castigó con sanciones a rusia
y desde entonces a putin no le ha
quedado otra que mirar más y más hacia
oriente y por cierto un apunte curioso
china todavía hoy sigue sin reconocer la
anexión rusa de crimea sorpresa
pero regresando al terreno económico
pensándolo bien china aparentemente es
un socio comercial perfecto para rusia
china tiene tecnología pero le faltan
recursos naturales mientras que a rusia
le sobra los recursos pero no tiene
tecnología así que blanco y en botella
desde 2014 el business entre moscú y
pekín no ha parado de crecer los datos
de 2021 hablan por sí solo el comercio
entre china y rúsia alcanza un récord de
más de 140 mil millones de dólares de
esta forma china se ha convertido en el
mayor mercado para las exportaciones
rusas después de la unión europea y la
mitad de lo que china le compra rusia es
petróleo crudo pero también compran
carbón gas natural y armas por su parte
los rusos han mostrado mucho pero que
mucho interés en la tecnología china no
les queda otra por ejemplo huawei está
llamado a jugar un papel destacado en el
desarrollo del 5g en russian bueno
cuando éste llegue quiero decir porque
claro hablando de rusia puede que donde
dice en 5g terminen convirtiéndose en
dos y medio y algún que otro mega yate
en chipre ya me entendéis el caso es que
en este punto estaban las relaciones
sino-rusas cuando putin desató su
tormenta de fuego y destrucción sobre
ucrania y la pregunta es cómo ha
reaccionado pekín al ataque pues bien
ahora mismo te lo contamos
[Música]
la guerra de putin
amigos en los últimos juegos olímpicos
de invierno china se impuso en el
medallero en las competiciones de
gimnasia ahora bien os aseguro que la
flexibilidad de los diplomáticos del
gigante asiático no tiene nada que
envidiar a la de sus gimnastas los que
seguís visual política habitualmente
seguro seguro que habéis oído hablar de
la conferencia de seguridad de múnich se
celebra todos los años en febrero y de
hecho visual político participó en la de
2020 pero esa es otra historia el caso
es que la conferencia del 2022 participó
por videoconferencia el ministro de
exteriores chino o allí y así de firme
se mostró cuando le preguntaron por las
tensiones en la frontera de ucrania ojo
quedaban cinco días para la invasión
fijaos sí
sí
eres
james capers
y el peine el senado ex action bien no
creo que se puede decir más alto pero no
más claro lo que pasa es que es muy
fácil ser tan contundente cuando el
statu quo se mantiene y todo estaba más
o menos tranquilo pero claro cuando de
repente sale putin en la tele y dice que
las tropas rusas se disponen a cruzar la
frontera a ella la cosa cambia por
completo y tal y como decimos emisor
político dicho y hecho
fue empezar la invasión y el gobierno
chino comenzó a mostrarse muy pero que
muy incómodo como que de repente tenían
que buscar excusas y justificaciones a
lo que putin estaba haciendo es más el
mismo 24 de febrero con la invasión ya
iniciada la portavoz del ministerio
chino de exteriores
joaquín intentó hasta convencernos de
que la guerra de ucrania ni siquiera
es historia rusia ha usado la artillería
y todos hemos visto las imágenes de
jarque fy mariupol devastadas por los
rusos así que china poco a poco empezó a
moverse a moverse así como de perfil
tratando de que no se les viera mucho el
problema el problema es que china
pertenece al consejo de seguridad de la
onu así que cuando este consejo se
reunió para pronunciarse sobre la
invasión de ucrania a china no le quedó
más remedio que votar y la pregunta es
qué pensáis que botó china
[Música]
pues amigos hizo lo mismo que con la
anexión de crimea abstenerse y evitar
criticar la actuación de putin bueno es
que ni siquiera los medios de
comunicación oficiales de china han
hablado de invasión de hecho el
representante de china en la onu wang
yong acusó a la otan de causar todos los
problemas ya sabéis la típica excusa
habitual de que la culpa de la agresión
es de todo el mundo menos de que la
lleva a cabo más
expansión y
expansión
pero al fin y al cabo qué otra cosa iba
decir china pero ojo porque esto tampoco
supone un respaldo claro para moscú y de
hecho desde entonces el gobierno chino
ha evitado dar más pasos en falso
mantiene que no le gusta lo que está
ocurriendo en ucrania que defiende su
integridad territorial y que apuesta por
resolver esta actuación mediante el
diálogo aún así también sostiene que
rusia tiene sus razones para actuar que
como se puede estar del lado del agresor
y del agredido al mismo tiempo pues el
historia no tengo ni idea supongo que
será cosa de hacer malabares el caso es
que está claro que china no gana nada
con esta guerra e incluso podríamos
llegar a decir que le importa más bien
poco está amigos es la guerra de putin y
a los chinos ni les va ni les viene no
van a quemar sus naves ni por rusia ni
por ucrania y mucho menos después de
haber visto cuál ha sido la reacción de
occidente
[Música]
suficientes problemas tienen ianchina
con la crisis inmobiliaria la
desaceleración económica y sus
tormentosas relaciones con los países
vecinos como para meterse en un
berenjenal sin sentido además todos
sabemos cuál es el principal objetivo de
china más aún teniendo en cuenta cómo se
está comportando en los últimos meses si
no ordena la mayor incursión de aviones
de combate en la zona de defensa de
taiwán desde octubre de hecho fueron
muchos los analistas que se preguntaron
si se impide no pensaba imitar a putin y
aprovechar la ocasión para invadir
taiwán claro que para el comunismo chino
las dos situaciones son muy diferentes
ucrania es un país soberano y reconocido
internacionalmente en cambio taiwán no
está reconocido como país soberano
prácticamente por ningún país ni
siquiera por los propios eeuu y derecho
poner en duda la soberanía de ucrania es
algo que juega directamente en contra de
la propia china ya que validaría que
otros hicieran lo mismo con taiwán que
pusieran en cuestión la soberanía china
que pekín tanto se empeña en defender
precisamente por eso el gobierno de
siempre parece tener claro que este no
es el momento de china eso sí la guerra
dukan ya les está sirviendo de
aprendizaje por ejemplo están viendo
cuáles son las armas que occidente está
dispuesto a utilizar para frenar a una
potencia nuclear
y además es que todo indica que ante una
invasión de taiwán la oposición de eeuu
sería todavía mayor al fin y al cabo
taiwán es su noveno socio comercial más
grande y toda una superpotencia en
semiconductores así mismo tenemos que
tener en cuenta que unas hipotéticas
sanciones para frenar el comercio con
occidente serían algo letal para la
economía china una economía que aún
depende de las importaciones de
occidente para poder operar muchos
sectores estratégicos y amigos esto nos
lleva directamente a una reflexión que
creo es importante la batería de
sanciones con las que los aliados no
dejan de bombardear económicamente amos
como podría tener una lectura más que
interesante en términos militares para
el mundo y especialmente para los
propios chinos si las nuevas guerras del
futuro ya no se libran sólo en el campo
de batalla quizás no sea tan prioritario
invertir más y más y más en tratar de
tener el ejército más fuerte y salvo si
eres vecino de la ley de putin claro
está pero no nos desviemos todo esto no
quiere decir que los chinos no se estén
planteando cómo sacar tajada del tiro en
el pie que se ha pegado putin para nada
fijaos
el botín de xi jinping
[Música]
amigos una de las sanciones más
importantes que se han impuesto contra
rusia es precisamente la que actúa
contra su banco central al que se le han
congelado sus reservas de divisas en
esta línea china puede haber tomado
buena nota porque evitar que en un
futuro le apliquen esta sanción a ella
puede resultarle clave al fin y al cabo
china es el país que tiene las mayores
reservas de divisas de todo el mundo
hablamos de aproximadamente el
equivalente a 3,22 millones de dólares
unas reservas en las que por cierto la
moneda estadounidense es la predominante
el gobierno de sikkim ping ha sido muy
crítico con las sanciones y no tiene por
qué aplicarlas pero lo cierto es que
como mínimo seguro que actuará con mucha
cautela antes de tomar cualquier
decisión que amenace su acceso al
sistema financiero internacional si ya
lo hizo con los suyos cuando eeuu
sancionó a algunos dirigentes de hong
kong que no hará con los rusos y en lo
que respecta al comercio tres cuartas
partes de lo mismo porque por mucho que
los intercambios con rusia batan récords
de momento apenas representan una décima
parte de su comercio combinado con ésta
dos unidos y la unión europea
pero entonces que podría querer china de
rusia a cambio de su respaldo si lo
pensáis bien tienen que ser cosas en las
que pekín salga muy beneficiada porque
en este momento aceptados con russian no
está bien visto
[Música]
pues bien por ejemplo un campo que
preocupa mucho a china es la seguridad
alimentaria antes de la guerra de los
precios mundiales de los alimentos ya
estaban en máximos de la última década y
ahora los expertos señalan que la
invasión de ucrania amenaza el
suministro mundial de trigo sin a
levantar restricciones a las
importaciones de trigo ruso y por
supuesto está el tema del gas su consumo
de gas natural se ha multiplicado por
tres en la última década y como la
producción nacional no llega a cubrir el
60 por ciento de su demanda el resto
pues lo tienen que importar la mayor
parte lo consiguen mediante gas natural
licuado el problema del gene l es que es
bastante más caro que el gas que llega
por gasoducto y seguro que aquí a muchos
os vendrá una pregunta a la cabeza hoy
enrique pero al caso rusia no es el gran
suministrador de gas a europa no podría
hacer acaso lo mismo con china pues sí
pero actualmente rusia apenas le ofrece
a china en torno al 15 por ciento del
gas que el gigante asiático importa
claro que un momento porque eso va a
cambiar bastante durante los próximos
años
[Música]
en 2019 entró en operación el gasoducto
power ops iberia que estará a pleno
rendimiento en el 2025 además en el
último encuentro entre putin y xi
jinping se cierra un acuerdo adicional
para suministrar gas a través de una
nueva ruta y la invasión de ucrania de
momento no ha cambiado nuestra tendencia
castró allana el camino hacia un nuevo
acuerdo de gas con china mientras las
sanciones golpean a rusia estamos
hablando del nuevo mega gasoductos o
youtube stock y amigos de completarse
esos tres proyectos la capacidad de
exportación de rusia de chinas se
multiplicaría lo que abarataría las
importaciones de gas chinas y además
incrementaría su seguridad de suministro
además teniendo en cuenta el nuevo
aislamiento que vive rusia seguro seguro
que china sabe cómo arrancar la crème en
las condiciones más favorables
[Música]
y de hecho las sanciones impuestas sobre
rusia nos llevan a pensar incluso que la
relación entre pekín y moscú se puede
desequilibrar aún más y que el kremlin
se vuelva muy pero que muy dependiente
de sus tratos con china entonces
entonces será el momento en el que el
régimen de xi jinping pondrá en práctica
una de sus especialidades favoritas la
diplomacia sugar daddy que es la
diplomacia sugar daddy pues os lo
explicamos en un pasado vídeo de visual
político
la oposición de rusia se ha debilitado
tanto que llega un punto en el que el
sugar daddy chino empieza a exigir cosas
a las que rusia simple y llanamente no
se podrá negar ahora bien realmente esta
china dispuesta a rescatar a la economía
rusa pues ojo porque en un próximo vídeo
aquí en visual políticos responderemos a
esta pregunta con todo lujo de detalles
así que no olvides suscribirte y darle a
la campanita pero de momento turno para
ti y papel pensáis que debería
desempeñar siguen pin ante la guerra de
ucrania creéis que china en algún
momento cambiará su postura de apoyar
simultáneamente las demandas de unos y
de otros podéis dejarnos vuestra
respuestas por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ahora si este vídeo se ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]